he actually has
and i think we all a lot of us can
relate to this has never outgrown his
lego obsession
but he's saying he's becoming
dangerously close to becoming the dad in
the lego movie
so let's not have the craggle let's have
all your kids play the legos please
everyone welcome matt yeah i am close to
being the dad from the lego movie and
yesterday i went to the lego store and i
ended up getting uh some lego succulents
that my wife wanted me to get so that'll
look nice in our house
alrighty so a little bit about myself to
start off i'm an actuary by trade and
what i want to talk to about today is
how r can be used to perform two core
actuarial tasks
first the performance of experience
studies and two assumption setting
when i began my career these tasks were
performed almost exclusively in
microsoft excel and access and there
were always time intensive mostly manual
processes that struggled with
reproducibility
and as a former excel jack i thought
about making this talk a before and
after story highlighting how we can get
more insights faster and with less
effort when we use r
but then i realized that would devolve
into me just dunking on excel for 20
minutes and i don't think anyone here
really wants to hear that
instead my goal here is really just to
discuss how r and data science can fit
into actuarial work and to demonstrate
that there's a lot of rich opportunities
for data scientists and actuaries like
me to collaborate
here's our agenda today
first we're going to do a little primer
on actuaries and actuarial modeling
since i'm
90 sure i might be the first actuary to
ever speak at this conference
then we're going to move on to a case
study that i cooked up involving
surrender rates on a deferred annuity
product so for the case study first
we're going to explore
our simulated experience data by
building uh powerful but simple
functions relying on dplyr
then we're going to fit models to that
experience using tidy models
lastly we're going to look at plugging
those models into a simplified actuarial
model to assess performance
so let's start with a question that i
get a lot what is an actuary now if
we're playing family feud the top
response that i usually get when i tell
people what i do is is that like an
accountant
the answer there is no but there's a
famous joke that every actuary knows
that goes an actuary is someone that
wanted to be an accountant but didn't
have the personality for it
yeah it's nice it's not true
not always
uh some other people you know know a
little bit about us and they'll say
aren't you that profession that has to
do all those exams and the answer there
is yes uh we're well known for our
gauntlet of roughly 10 exams required to
get full fellowship in the society of
actuaries uh in fact i put a little gif
out here from the soa's website around
our exam requirements because it's
gotten this complicated that they had to
build an interactive site to explain it
all
but here's a definition of actuary that
i like
an actuary is someone who uses
statistics financial math and deep
domain expertise to quantify price and
manage risks
origins of this profession go back to
17th century europe
and we're one of the first true data
professions to emerge
and you typically see actuaries
practicing and insurance think life and
annuity health or property and
casualties and our professional
organization in the us and canada the
society of actuaries has about 32 000
members worldwide
alrighty let's move on to actuarial
models
when i say the word model in front of
this audience most of you are probably
thinking about statistical or machine
learning models
actuarial models are a little different
they're long-term projection engines of
insurance blocks often spanning periods
of 50 years or so
there's usually a focus on forecasting
cash flows think things like premium
payments claim disbursements investment
income and expenses
using actuarial models companies can
value blocks of business to ensure
they're holding the correct level of
assets now and in the future to meet the
promises that they make to their
customers
also models can be used to set prices on
new products or to implement critical
risk management strategies
a key aspect of actual models is that
they're heavily dependent on assumptions
assumptions can really include anything
like economics management actions
expectations for future mortality rates
and customer behavior the latter of
which we're focusing on today
and it's extremely important to get uh
robust assumptions into our models
because if those assumptions are poor
we're going to have a big garbage in
garbage out problem and that's going to
lead to
unsuccessful business results
all right so here's one simple actual
model that we're going to play a little
bit with today the actuarial present
value
they don't all like they don't all look
like this this one just happens to apply
to a product that includes death
benefits
surrender benefits withdrawals and no
future premiums
the formula here just describes a
probability weighted present value of
future cash flows in each time step
we're calculating the probability of
survival
times expected claims times a discount
factor
and death benefits here occur with
probability q d surrenders occur occur
with probability q s and withdrawals are
only dependent upon survival
all right now let's move on to
experience studies
experience studies are what they sound
like they're just formal reports of
experience
some common variables and studies are
mortality rates surrender rates claim
incidence and benefit utilization rates
and we actually use experienced study
data to perform to inform decisions
about assumptions that go into our
models
and before we get into examples i need
to finally introduce the data set that
we're going to be using in these case
studies
this data set is based on simulated
experience for a deferred annuity
product
i'm using simulated data here because
real insurance data usually is some
combination of expensive or proprietary
or just too darn massive to include in a
20-minute talk
and uh also since this is simulated data
i just want to keep in mind here that
any
results shown in the following slides
are really just purely illustrative and
they're not meant to represent any
particular product or company's
experience
the data here that we're looking at is a
census of annuity policies some active
and some that terminated due to
surrenders
and i've split that data set into a
training and test set
the target variable in the data set is
called term which indicates whether or
not the customer surrendered their
contract so this is really going to be a
classification problem for us
however since the eventual goal of this
experience study and assumption setting
is to
create an assumption for an actuarial
model what we're really going to be
interested in
is
the probability of term being equal to
one
and also i just want to note that since
this is simulated data there is such a
thing as a correct surrender rate that
exists and we'll be seeing that in some
of the upcoming examples
uh some key features on this data set we
have i'll point out three the age of the
policy in years
uh two the issue age of the customer and
then three it's a field called inc gear
which we'll see a lot which is an
indicator as to whether the product was
sold with an optional guaranteed income
benefit
which is a common uh type of insurance
benefit on annuities that provides a
fixed amount of income for life even
after the annuities account balance
drains to nothing
all right and here's a typical exhibit
you might see in experience studies
this is just a crosstab that shows
experience by policy year
usually in these types of crosstabs it
will compare actual experience versus
expected experience
and expected experience tends to come
from either an industry assumption or it
might be a prior assumption that was
derived the last time we did an analysis
of experience
so let's say we want to go we want to go
ahead and create a crosstab similar to
the prior slide
one way to go about that is to create a
data set containing n rows per policy
where n is the number of years that the
policy has been enforced
i call this data exposed data
in exposed data the last record for
every policy is either going to end in a
surrender or it won't because the data
itself is right censored
there's two ways to go about creating
exposed data first would be if we had a
huge robust data warehouse we could run
a massive query to select data at
various points in time but that tends
not always that's not always feasible
due to things like system conversions
and mergers and acquisition activities a
lot of times that historical data isn't
always available to us
another option and one that we're going
to look at here would be if we have a
policy census like our sample data
we can manufacture prior period results
using basic dplyr
so here's a function that allows us to
do that
this exposure function is going to
convert our census data into exposure
data
and the trick here really is just to use
dplyr's slice function in conjunction
with base r's repeat
in the table below we can see that the
first policy policy number one is
repeated six times
because it's currently in the sixth
policy year
so after we go ahead and do this big
slice operation and increase the size of
our data set from around 20 000 to 150
000 records
we can also go back and then correct any
features that should vary over time so
here i'm going to increment age every
year
and i'm also going to make sure that
that term indicator is always zero until
the last observation point when i know
where this policy landed either in this
render or not
all right now that we have our exposed
data we also need a function to
summarize results again we're going to
use just some basic d plier so we have
this function called exp stats
and it's really just a summarized call
also if we have a prior view of expected
experience this function can calculate a
ubiquitous experience study metric
called the actual to expected or a to e
ratio
so in this slide what i've done is i've
attached our correct surrender
probabilities
and just printed the results that i get
out of this and no surprise since this
is simulated data i'm getting an actual
to expected of around 100
all right so these next two slides
they're going to cover two key drivers
of surrender behavior
um and one thing i like about this slide
it's highlighting one of my favorite
things about programming with dplyr
uh
one great thing about that package is
that it's very easy to create functions
that naturally respect group data frames
so here i'm going to group by the policy
year variable call exp stats and i can
get results that look like the plot on
this screen here
when we look at the data here we can see
that for the first 10 years surrender
rates are kind of slowly increasing and
then in a year in year 11 they rock it
up
and eventually settle down to an
elevated level afterwards
and this is really typical for this type
of product um it's driven by the fact
that these products often come with uh
surrender penalties that charge
customers for uh unwinding the product
and those penalties usually last between
five and ten years and in this example
there's a ten-year period
this next plot adds another grouping
variable for the presence of the income
guarantee
as you can see the guarantee makes
customers much less likely to surrender
and besides policy or this happens to be
the top driver of customer behavior
this particular feature is something an
experienced actuary would know to use
but let's say we're new to this type of
product and we're not sure which
variables to investigate first what can
we do
one answer is that we can build a quick
variable importance plot
so in the above
we're gonna set up a quick recipe uh
using the ranger package and we're gonna
ignore any non non-feature data like
policy numbers and i'm also gonna throw
out the correct surrender probabilities
because that is definitely cheating
uh then we're gonna create a model spec
with ranger as the engine
and importantly we need to
set the re set the packages engine
specific importance argument because if
we don't we're not going to save any of
that useful importance data
lastly we're going to build a workflow
and call the fit function
and after our model's been fit we can
easily create an importance plot like
this here
using the vip function from the vip
package
what's interesting to me about this plot
is that the age and withdrawal age wdh
columns were listed as more prominent
than the income guarantee and i wasn't
expecting that but i know why it's
happening
one of the drivers of the behavior that
i included in the simulated data was the
age the customer elected to start
receiving guaranteed income payments and
at certain ages this can be extremely
impactful which drove up these
age-related features and prominence
and this little insight to me was one of
the reasons why i like variable
importance plots so much whether you're
you know an experienced actuary like me
or a new hire they're really a great
tool for highlighting drivers of
behavior that might not be top of mind
for you
all right so now that we've discussed
experience studies let's move on to
assumption setting
our goal in this section is to fit a few
models of surrender rates based on
observed experience and to compare
predictions against the correct
assumption used to generate the data
first we're going to look at a
traditional actuarial approach of
setting an assumption based on tables
and
next we're going to look at two
predictive models we're going to use
we're going to use tidy models and we're
going to create a logistic and random
forest model
up first is our traditional approach
first we're going to build a quick
crosstab table using that exp stats
function from the prior section
and we're also going to group by policy
or an income guarantee
and that gives us an assumption like
this which looks just like the plot you
saw before
from here we could also decide to apply
rounding or smoothing or any other
adjustments we think
would help deal with non-intuitive data
one unavoidable question that pops up in
assumption setting all the time is how
do we handle unobserved time periods
that we need in our actuarial models and
this is where expertise and professional
judgment come into play
for this example we run out of
experience data after year 15 but our
model requires us to make some
assumption for what's going to happen
past that point so we got to figure out
what we're going to do and what we're
going to do for this example and this
isn't always the right answer but we're
just going to use a naive forecast which
is going to assume that future surrender
rates are going to be equal to the last
observed value
all right now let's move on to some
predictive models first we're going to
start with logistic regression
we're going to create a model spec
and then we're going to create a recipe
that allows us to capture some of those
non-linear patterns in surrender rates
and i'm also going to tack on some
useful interaction terms that i know are
going to work well for this problem
next we just combine this model spec
into a workflow and lastly we're going
to call fit
and here's how our model compared to
observed and correct experience
we're looking in this plot at the policy
year and the income guarantee variable
generally we have a pretty good fit here
except after year 12 or 13 the model
surrender rates decline a bit too fast
given the linear nature of this model
now let's look forward to the random
forest model
and it's like kind of highlights one of
the things i like about tidy models this
code is virtually identical to the
previous slide the only real difference
here is that i um added the random
forest function specified that i want to
use ranger instead of the glm function
i'm leaving pre-processing here almost
unchanged but i should also mention here
that typically this level of engineering
isn't necessary for
this type of model however since this
example doesn't include any tuning of
hyper parameters i wanted to just i
wanted to add some feature engineering
to ensure i'm going to get a decent fit
under the default configuration
in terms of performance no surprise here
this model looks even better than the
logistic
okay so we created all these assumption
models what's next
if this were a typical machine learning
framework we'd compare our performance
against a test data set using common
performance metrics like roc area under
the curve or mean lock mean log loss etc
but in this section we're going to do
something a bit non-traditional by
testing performance with an actuarial
present value model
i'm going to gloss over the coding
details in this section but here's the
general process we're following first
we're going to grab our test data which
happens to have a little over four
thousand active policies
next we're going to generate vectors of
future surrender surrender probabilities
under each assumption
third we're going to calculate actual
present values for each policy under
each of our three assumptions
and we're going to use that formula that
i introduced earlier
and lastly we're going to assess
performance and our key question here is
going to be which assumption
yields results
that are closest to the correct
assumption
however before before we can move into
any of these actuarial values though we
need to make a few extra assumptions
that i've listed here i'm not going to
belabor all these um and for our
purposes we can just assume that these
are set in stone however it should be
noted that if this were a real actuarial
model each one of these items would
require its own detailed assumption
setting process as well
okay here's how our model's performed
the total actual present values under
each assumption are
almost indistinguishable from one
another
um all actual to expected ratios are
around 100
and it looks like there's a slight edge
with the random force that's a little
bit closer to the pin
i'm a little bit surprised with these
results with the traditional model
because it looks like it's holding up
pretty well
and i think that's due to some
combination of luck
possibly an indication that the
simulated data here is a little bit too
simplistic and not random enough
and also the fact that
the hyper parameters in our machine
learning models weren't optimized so it
didn't necessarily give them a true a
chance to shine
shifting over to the rmse column the
logistic model really stands out so
let's take a look and see what's going
on with that
and here's what's happening so as i
noted earlier the fit to surrender rates
after year 12 is pretty poor
in addition uh
i'm you can guess that the extrapolation
beyond year 15 is probably driving
towards surrender rates that are
unrealistically low
so what can we do to improve the fit of
this particular model
one approach is that we can apply
judgment like we did before with our
traditional actuarial model
and
here if we look at let's say capping the
policy year variable at 15 and
regenerating surrender predictions
now we can see that the logistic model
looks a lot better
it's still not as close to the random
force to the correct result if you look
at the absolute difference column
uh however the rmse looks much better in
fact it stands out amongst the um
the other assumption bases
uh before we wrap i wanted to show one
last plot comparing the distribution of
residuals between our modeled actuarial
present values and the correct values
a random forest model appears to be
normally distributed with residuals
close to zero
our traditional model
while appearing competitive on the prior
or sorry a logistic model has a mode of
roughly zero but it's clearly skewed and
our traditional model although it
appeared somewhat competitive on the
prior slides it's exhibiting a pretty
wide range of outcomes and the mode
isn't even um
at zero
and uh you know
none of these are ideal observations and
i think a lot of that is due to just
some of the overly simplistic
assumptions that that model's making by
only considering two features
all right so let's wrap up what have we
learned here
modern tools like r and tidy model save
time and unlock deeper insults or
insights resulting in more precise
models
thank you mr freud
assumption model or in assumption
settings should consider should consider
downstream usage in actuarial models
and one last lesson i learned here is
that while algorithms and machine
learning models are really cool they're
not a panacea
expertise uh really matters and
professional judgment is still required
and often unavoidable especially when
you're projecting into the unknown
all right that's it thank you everyone
nerd